you know it's a nerve-wracking night for
me I can't imagine how it feels for you
you know I I it's it's just exciting
it's just exciting to be a part of us a
dream really right especially the SAG
Awards I mean you're in a room full of
your peers who have recognized you in
this way for your performance what does
that mean to you well I just I think
back to that that little kid that was
you know walking around in different
colored t-shirts and as an extra in TV
shows as a kid and I just think what
would he make all this so special I mean
especially when you see your journey you
know you've mentioned it before that
it's all part of the same path right
starting with Zoe 101 to hear uh what
would you tell that young Austin right
now
oh just I don't know I just keep with it
you know and focus on the work not all
the noise around it yeah
you've been nominated for an Oscar
congratulations
um you know last we spoke with you is at
the Golden Globes with Lisa Marie what
does it mean to you that now you are not
only honoring Elvis's Legacy but also
Lisa's
um
it's just part of that profound
privilege that I feel uh
to to be linked to them in some way that
they're I mean Lisa was such an
extraordinary woman
um so the times that I spent with her
were some of the greatest Gifts of my
life and and so now I'd be able to carry
on her Legacy in this way I'm feeling
profoundly honored may I ask who you
bring into the Oscars
um well so I got my dad here tonight
okay this is his first time at one of
these sister at the Globes right Globes
and then um one of my best friends since
I was 17.
there's a guy named James who he uh he
then became my agent and so I wouldn't
have my life as an actor without him and
so it's it's my you know my profound
privilege to get to bring him with me
that would be a fun night all right
congratulations good to see you